hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the latest
insane reveals surrounding the secret
history of yami
and the black bulls including the tragic
truth about knocked
deadly deal with a devil we just learned
a lot about the past of the mysterious
black bulls
vice captain but this information also
has
massive consequences for the future of
the story so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the black lore content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going you know what to do leave
a like
and comment it only takes a second but
because of the youtube algorithm it
actually helps a lot
and of course if you're new to the
channel or maybe you've been watching my
videos but you haven't subscribed yet do
me a favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain black lower manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have
been warned first let's clear up some of
the translation issues from the previous
chapter the official translation on
viz.com confirmed that the events of the
previous chapter are happening a few
minutes before the heart kingdom gang
arrived
not a few hours i figured that this was
the case and i mentioned that in my
previous video
but that type of stuff will happen
sometimes because it takes me a day or
two to actually produce
a video so if i want to get it out to
you guys around the same time that the
official chapter drops
i have to accept some potential early
translation errors
we also learned that noct's fourth
devil's name is not
war gunner but rather waldner this also
makes sense because war gunner sounds
more like a character from apex legends
in the latest chapter we take a deep
dive into knocked
backstory and we learned the tragic
truth about his twin brother
morgan even though the two brothers
looked identical as kids
their personalities couldn't be more
different
noct only cared about himself and having
fun and he was a delinquent meanwhile
morgan was a kind boy who always wanted
to help
others he loved everyone and he was
loved by everyone
knocked felt that even though he and his
brother looked a lot alike
they were actually a totally different
species so eventually noct completely
changed his own appearance
in order to better fit his bad boy
delinquent persona
it seems that he wanted his physical
appearance to reflect the fact that he
and his brother were completely
different
it turns out that it was actually
knocked not morgan who first became
friends with yami nakt had heard about
yami because of yami's rare dark magic
so he went out to find him and soon they
bonded over their similar magic types
and became friends
they were known around town for hanging
out together and being troublemakers
but then when it came time for yami to
join the magic knights
he ended up joining the same squad as
noct's brother morgan
nakht didn't think that yami was the
type of person who was well suited for
the magic knights
but yami became friends with morgan and
morgan helped him get used to being a
magic knight
morgan believed that his brother knocked
had incredible magic talent
and that he should also join the magic
knights but
knocked refused because he had no
interest in becoming a magic knight he
just didn't see the point
when knocked eventually turned 18 his
parents
summoned him and told him the secret of
the faust
family the faust family had secretly
dedicated itself to studying forbidden
magic
and devil magic and since noct was a
shadow magic user and someone who
clearly had no attachment to the rules
and laws of the clover kingdom
knocked was actually the ideal candidate
to inherit
the forbidden legacy of the faust family
in that moment noct realized that he
wasn't
the one who was different in fact he fit
right in with his family morgan was the
one who stood out
his goodness kindness and respect for
laws
made morgan the black sheep of the faust
family
knocked was fascinated by the prospect
of studying devil magic
and attaining its incredible forbidden
power so while yami and morgan focused
on being magic knights
knocked focused on unlocking the power
of devils
he managed to make a contract with four
devils really quickly
which led his father to conclude that
noct must be a genius
since he appeared to be so uniquely
gifted in the ways of devil magic
noct's father suggested that noct could
be strong enough to make a contract with
the highest
ranking devil this devil is the ruler of
the underworld
and the unofficial translation calls him
lucy fugus
but his description reminds me a lot of
lucifer himself
we know that lucifer is known for being
the highest ranking devil
and a user of gravity magic and gravity
magic was
mentioned here as well so we'll have to
wait for the official translation to see
whether lucy fugus
is just another name for lucifer or
whether this is a completely different
devil meanwhile morgan found out what
was going to happen
so he infiltrated the ritual and he
tried to stop his brother
as a magic knight morgan had a duty to
stop forbidden magic from being
practiced but even more than that
morgan knew that attempting to make a
contract with lucy fugus was extremely
dangerous however noct was excited by
the prospect of making a contract with
the highest ranking devil
and so his ambition and curiosity got
the better of him
he vowed to surpass his limits and then
he summoned
lucy fugus but as you might expect
it all went horribly wrong pretty much
immediately the immense power of
lucifugus could not be contained
and it began attacking everyone in the
surrounding area even though this should
have been impossible since a summoned
the devil should only be able to
interact with the executor of the ritual
noct himself was paralyzed and he
couldn't even move
and in that moment he realized that
highest ranking devils are not something
that humans should try to mess with
it seems to me that the four devils that
knocked made a contract with in the past
are lower tier devils kind of like liebe
but the highest tier devils like lucy
fugus are something else
altogether morgan then interferes in the
ritual in order to stop it
he breaks the relic that initiated the
ritual and this
stops the ritual and saves noct's life
but morgan himself is killed as a result
of his interference
morgan whose dream was to protect the
piece as a magic knight and whose magic
appears to have been light-based
tragically dies
in his brother's arms knocked is
absolutely heartbroken he begs god to
save his brother
and take him instead because morgan did
nothing wrong
morgan was always a good person and if
anyone deserved to die here
it was knocked not morgan but
it was too late nocht spent his entire
life
up to that point doing whatever he
wanted including messing with forbidden
magic
and willingly engaging in extremely
dangerous rituals
now the chickens have come home to roost
but the victim was not
knocked himself the victim was his
beloved brother
morgan knocked of course feels a
tremendous amount of guilt because of
this
and he simply cannot forgive himself i
assume that he ended up joining the
black bulls and
took on the appearance of his brother as
a way of repenting for his mistakes and
his sins
even though he himself never wanted to
become a magic knight
noct decided to honor his brother by
trying to fulfill morgan's dream of
protecting the peace
as a magic knight back in the present
moment
the impaled knocked opens his eyes and
looks
right at lilith and namah he vows to
surpass
his limits once again and he vows to
destroy the evil that lies before him
and that is how this crazy and tragic
chapter
ends whoa what an interesting backstory
and i can't even imagine what noct has
been through
since the death of his brother it's
clear that he blames himself for what
happened to morgan and that he lives
with this crushing guilt
every single day of his life and that is
not an easy way to live
but now i'm wondering what noct is about
to do
next is he going to reveal a hidden
power-up that will make him strong
enough to put up a fight
against lilith and the ma at least for a
little while
or is he going to try to do something
even crazier like summoning another
devil
maybe even this mysterious lucy fugus
and speaking of which
who is this lucy fugus is this just
another name for lucifer
or is it a totally different devil and
if this is a different devil
is he also somewhere at the bottom of
the tree of cliffhoth and what is his
relationship with lucifer
are they allies or rivals the official
translation might explain a lot of this
so i can't wait to find out more
definitely let me know what you guys
think
is knocked about to reveal a new power
up will he try to summon
another devil will he push himself too
hard and get himself
killed or will he somehow survive this
treacherous battle
maybe osto or someone else will arrive
just in time to save him
share your thoughts down in the comments
below i look forward to hearing from you
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content right
here on the channel please leave that
like to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
animal pro or maybe you watch our videos
but you still haven't subscribed
please make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
acquired respect pate heffa liam
thompson algertol
dr cortman dustin scarlett emperor otaku
spidey life chanel
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and yuno
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
rathune de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joanne
garcia
the red-haired raven ted no ted
isparky65
fatboy games deadly saint and soul race
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
my
[Music]
you